[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Midas touch
Network's coverage of the January 6
select hearing sorry about the technical
issues that we've had uh hopefully you
were able to stay tuned for the entire
hearing we have the post coverage right
here live with you on the Midas touch
network uh thank you for joining us
thank you for sticking around through
our technical difficulties the first
guest I want to bring in to the live
post coverage here is Trump's former
attorney and I want to get his immediate
reaction
after
what has transpired with the January 6
elect Committee in the referrals that
they gave to Donald Trump so I want
everyone to welcome Michael Cohen
Michael how are you oh I am hanging in
there my friend how are you Tony Oh I'm
great I'm great it's good to see you
um again I'm I appreciate you uh hanging
with us here and getting your immediate
reaction right after the hearing as they
voted affirmative to give criminal
referrals to the Department of Justice
for Donald Trump so give us your first
first immediate thoughts about my
immediate thought Tony to be honest with
you I think it's the same as probably
all of your listeners and um all of the
Midas Mighty that this was expected what
else could they possibly have done this
committee has spent legitimately
one full year seven days a week 24 hours
a day in terms of obtaining testimony
from Witnesses on top of that they have
reviewed something like close to a
million documents after all this work
that was done after all the information
that was um obtained and after all the
information that was provided to the
American people
it was unquestionable that they had
everything that was needed in order to
make the referral to the doj you know
the interesting one that I thought uh
though I enjoyed every single one of the
members uh closing statements Adam
kinzinger's was one that sort of hit
home you know to me which is about the
Department of Justice and how Donald
Trump weaponized it which is exactly the
scenario that I talk about in my book
Revenge that Donald Trump figured out
how to weaponize the Department of
Justice for his own purpose and I I
really appreciated Adam kinzinger's
statements that this could lead to the
end of democracy which is why it's so
important that the referral be made
well I I couldn't agree with those
statements more that um well let me ask
you though
do you think that this has
any sway on what the work of the
Department of Justice is already doing
or is this more for the American people
to see that the January 6th select
committee did their work collected the
evidence and gave the appropriate
accountability that they are able to lay
upon the actors here as as you would
call them Donald Trump himself the
former president who tried to subvert
our democracy do you think that it's
more ceremonial and and giving the
American people the sense that hey we
are at a point where a former president
will be indicted criminally in the
federal court well Tony to answer the
first part of your question again I
don't believe that there's anybody
whether it's on that are now connected
into your show right here or
legitimately anyone Republican Democrat
or independent that doesn't believe that
the January 6 committee did
a very you know lengthy and very
thorough job you may some people may not
like the decision right because they're
part of the Maga group but at the end of
the day nobody can say that they did not
do a very thorough job that being said
um all that they've done now is make the
referral to the Department of Justice
for
um indictments and criminal review now
we all know that that will be going to
Merrick Garland and none of us and I
don't believe the committee knows either
exactly what they have been doing so far
Lord knows that the department of
justice under Merrick Garland operates
slower than molasses through a strainer
and on top of that just because the
committee makes this referral does not
mean that doj
um has to do it I mean there's
absolutely
um no legal weight into
um
the committee's determination and what
Merrick Garland and the doj will
ultimately do
I I think I think you're correct about
that because we've no actually I know
well right correct but here's the thing
we we have seen the referrals to the doj
uh Steve Bannon Peter Navarro which
Steve Bannon resulted in
um the the indictment and the conviction
now we're waiting on a a
um an appeal here for for Bannon but
Mark Meadows
um actually received a referral and we
haven't seen that come to light yet
um what I I do want to get one other
sense from you too is about Hope Hicks
because this
um footage that we've seen of Hope Hicks
testimony we have not seen this before
um what do you make of Hope Hicks
because you were always with Donald
Trump for a long time as his former
lawyer and kind of got a sense of his
mindset does it sound like Donald Trump
what hope Hicks described that it would
he was more worried about his legacy
because he didn't want to be known as a
loser which he is a total loser um in so
many forms in fashion but it was all
about only winning it was only winning
he didn't care about her democracy he
didn't care about her history he didn't
care about the Constitution he didn't
care about the peaceful transfer of
power he didn't care about uh citizens
votes he only cared that his legacy
would have winning yeah well look I know
hope Hicks very well
um hope was there from the very very
beginning you know after I had
pushed the issue and made the
determination that he was going to end
up running uh going back for the 2016
election number two there was actually
hope Hicks so she's been around a while
hope is a very honest
um you know young lady and to be very
Frank
she is spot on in terms of word for word
what Donald Trump would say he doesn't
care and how many times Tony have you
and I had this conversation or have I
had it with um you know Ben Brett or
Jordy
um whereby I said Donald Trump doesn't
care about anyone or anything other than
himself he doesn't care about the
country he's willing to burn the country
down because the country rejected him in
the re-election hope is spot on in what
she said that's all that he cares about
would be his legacy and the fact that he
lost so look
um I have no doubt that everything that
she told the January 6th committee is
accurate she has
her entire future ahead of her and the
last thing she's going to do is to
jeopardize it for a man that she has
seen
throw under the bus meaning myself and
others time and time again
um she doesn't want to be that next
person she wants to you know go on with
her life which she's of course entitled
to do
well Michael I appreciate you joining us
give us give us one last thought what
was the the main takeaway that you think
ultimately the American people will
remember from this hearing today
that Trump's Behavior
and I think it was Liz Cheney who made
once again just a very powerful and a
very poignant statement about her
family's history on how her great great
great great grandfather had four four
years in the Civil War and that no
president in the history of this country
has ever done
to the rule of law what Donald Trump has
done and you know there's the very
famous clip of me sitting before the
house oversight committee whereby I
stated that my biggest fear is that if
Donald Trump loses the election that
there will never be a peaceful transfer
of power now you have to think about how
wacky that that statement must have
sounded to so many people considering it
has never ever happened in the history
of this country and yet lo and behold
Daryl Donald number 45 steps up and he
decides he doesn't want to give up power
he didn't do for example like what
George Washington and every president
thereafter has done which is to concede
the power because that's what the
Democracy calls for that's what our
constitution calls for not only did he
not do that recently he's even talked
about tearing up Constitution which
would give him the ability somehow in
his warped thinking and in his mind that
he would have the ability to then throw
Joe Biden out of the Oval Office and
resume power this is not a normal human
being this is the mindset of an
autocratic fascist Monarch dictator you
know wannabe who literally believes that
the United States belongs to him and
that his legacy can only be had if in
fact he becomes president of the United
States ad infinitum and I can assure you
none of us want that that would forget
about being a danger to our democracy
that would be the extinction to
democracy and I don't just believe here
in America I believe around the world so
I think Liz Cheney's statement about
how no other president has ever done
this and that's why this document
coupled with the Mueller report document
as both historic documents that need to
be taught in schools colleges law
schools and so on that it's so important
because
look once you lose your democracy you
know that you're never getting it back
and that's exactly what Trump and his
acolytes are trying to do and we
collectively must be extremely extremely
cautious as we move forward into this
next election in two years we must be
extremely cautious and concerned about
who the Republican Party May ultimately
put up because Donald is not the only
one who believes in this ideology
Michael um thank you very much for
joining us and I always appreciate your
commentary and I I want to tell you that
um I was trying to get that clip
together with the technical difficulties
we had I wasn't able to get it of you
stating that if Donald Trump lost he
would not
um have a peaceful transfer of power and
I appreciate you telling the world that
in that moment even though we weren't to
the moment that anyone would dream that
a president of the United States
wouldn't transfer the power of democracy
peacefully
um to the rightful winner
um so you know Tony there's additionally
one this it was so poignant the entire
you know hour-long hearing that there's
actually one additional part as well
that you know can't be ignored here and
the the whole purpose of this January
6th hearing is to hold people
accountable and when I say holding
people accountable we all know what the
doj we know what government not only
have they done to people like myself but
and to others but what they have failed
to do so far to those who are in power
and I want to just recall for your for
the listeners that are on with us right
now that there's this whole issue of
people like Kevin McCarthy
um Jim Jordan dance Gavino there's a
whole slew of them who refuse to testify
before the committee despite the fact
that they were subpoenaed and I want
every single person right now with us to
understand that if that was you
you would be like well like Steve Bannon
you would have been
you know found guilty and you'd be
incarcerated so you know I want people
to understand that while we [ __ ]
each other and we don't say things like
I do or you do or that you get on this
program
law is not equally distributed in this
country and the whole notion that lady
Justice wears a blindfold you know so
that everybody has Justice equally under
the eyes of the law it's not true people
like Donald Trump have been getting away
with things for so long now
and we're also anxious to see him held
accountable and yet
when is that going to happen when is
Merrick Garland going to jump on the
bicycle and start pedaling really fast
because what do we have another two
weeks or so before the house changes the
power in the house changes and I promise
you if in fact and it looks like Jim
Jordan which to me it's so infuriating
because this is a man who shouldn't even
be allowed to to walk through the halls
of Congress based upon his past this is
a man who has no respect for anyone or
anything and I've been before him three
separate times and I can tell you he's
not the one who we want to you know be
the majority leader there in the house
if he becomes the majority leader he's
going to end up becoming a puppet for
Trump which puts all of us in Jeopardy
and that's why I keep trying to say the
more people that they could bring into
and I'm talking that to the listeners to
bring into the mightiest Mighty Camp to
bring into the mayor culpa Camp to to
stay involved and to stay aggressive
with all of us and the things that we're
doing that's the only way we're going to
get rid of people like the Gin Jordan's
of the world so that people are held
accountable for their improper actions
for their illegalities it's extremely
important if we want to turn this
country over to our children
grandchildren God willing
great-grandchildren for you know
generations to come knowing that it's
democracy that they live under it's so
important I can't stress it enough
I think you're absolutely right in
pro-democracy speech and we must lean
into democracy at at all cost um and we
can't just say well the 2022 midterms
are over uh we got two years until the
next election we got two years to lean
in and make sure that we do what we did
in 2020 and 2022
um even more in 2024 Michael Cohen
thanks for joining us I really
appreciate you joining us friend uh
we'll see you soon thank you oh I look
forward to it Tony uh Michael Cohen
there I want to bring in some political
strategists my favorite political
strategist sorry David Bender Dr Rachel
bittickoffer and David Bender as well I
want to bring them in uh David I I
apologize doctor
she's always my favorite it's my
favorite too
why I know you're on limited time Rachel
so give us your take
um on what you what you witnessed here
of the hearing um what is the most
significant moment to you
crimes against democracy right I mean
that's that's what these criminal
referrals are about that the president
of the United States committed crimes
against democracy and they have now
referred him for criminal investigation
by the doj we have to we have to assume
and I think that there's some evidence
to support this things aren't moving at
doj and the uh bringing in of Jack Smith
post-election we've seen just a real
Pace change so I you know I get
Michael's frustration though to date
there's exactly one Trump official who's
been Health accountable for Donald you
know for the Donald Trump crime cabal
and that's my book and all right he's
the only one because the rest of them
you know bought their pardons for coup
at the end of the Trump Administration
so we are still in a position where
we've had zero Justice and um you know
Michael's exactly right we have to keep
the focus on 2024 we have a party that
punished every person that tried to make
sure that we had a peaceful transfer of
power I mean some they were unsuccessful
they tried to primary out Brian Kemp and
failed in Georgia and
um you know Rusty Bowers though the
Arizona speaker of the house he's gone
he lost his his seat there you know
nobody has been held to account uh by
the Republican party for standing for
um you know everyone who has been a hold
of account by the party has been has
been the people who stood up for the
rule of law against Donald Trump that
means to me that the party itself still
presents a very live existential threat
to the stability of the rule of law and
the continuation of American democracy
and therefore we must be painting them
with a broad brush I mean when people
ask me well who you know who who are the
good Republicans I can only really think
of two two people who were willing to
put their careers aside to stand up for
the truth of rule of law and that's Adam
kinsinger and Liz Cheney okay everybody
else to some extent there's some other
people who have been occasional or
modest critics but they haven't really
stood up to the party and the fact is
that both Liz Cheney and Adam kitzinger
were removed for doing so so we really
are facing a party-wide you know threat
with the Republicans and we have to make
sure that America
sees the um you know collection or
consolidation of power under Republicans
right now as an existential threat
Rachel can I ask you a question
we haven't talked it's good to see you
uh we haven't talked since the midterms
have you uh seen any numbers that show
the degree to which these hearings and
everything that came out of them
affected the margin in many of these
races we saw Elaine Larry lost her race
to reelection but in so many other cases
it seems like democracy was on the
ballot at least to some degree in Senate
and House races what what do you see
yeah let's talk about what happened in
the midterms I mean in the midterm we
knew we were I mean at least those of us
with clear eyes and um you know
willingness to to say so or a capability
to say so knew that we're going to be
facing a really tough midterm
fundamental you're the end party you're
going to lose uh 40 you know 40 50 years
of data only twice have we seen that
disrupted and uh we so you know
understanding that that was going to be
a major threat I had been arguing let's
make we have to make the electorate
think about the opposition party about
the Republican party and see them as a
threat to democracy otherwise this
midterm will play out on traditional
fundamentals which is you know is the
economy good and who's the end party
and so you know that was a lot of there
was a lot of process and a lot of other
people both working with and
independently of me to push that onto
the agenda it was really important to
get the white house uh President Biden
to embrace that message to legitimate it
so I didn't sound like tin foil hat
chatter from the Grassroots right
um and I and and you know his and I mean
to me he is absolutely the leader for
this time because he was willing to do
it it was absolutely politically
dangerous for Joe Biden especially with
his reputation his own brand of being
like bipartisan Joe to come out and tell
America hey our democracy is under
attack existential threat from the
opposition party that is not a speech a
President Biden would wake up and be
like hey I get to go go tell Republic
tell America Republicans are a threat to
democracy this is not something he would
relish at all and so it was really
important to legitimate it I think from
the top down to have important political
leaders like Biden and others Jamie
Harrison the chair of the DNC willing to
say this election will determine whether
we have free and fair elections and thus
democracy so we managed to do that but
you know just yesterday I was reminded
about how much of a lift that was
um starting in January of 21 22 to 23 uh
January February March of 21 to start to
see this conversation effort to make the
Virginia cycle about CRT a fake issue a
completely contrived Scandal and
controversy and after a couple of months
of that effort what upholsters do they
start putting CRT into the most
important issue list okay do you know
what wasn't in the most important issue
list of most surveys or any that I saw
anyway prior to that was threat to
democracy even though they had tried to
overthrow the [ __ ] government right
like so like I had to basically shame
America's pollsters I'm like you know
yeah so it's true that you might you're
going to get people who are answering
for um CRT is their most important issue
because they're being primed that by
Republicans you're going to put a fake
[ __ ] issue in there and legitimate it
by the way because soon as it pops up
well then it must be a thing it's got to
be an issue right it's on the list CRT
it must be an issue and you still
haven't put threat to democracy when the
other party's telling you 70 [ __ ]
percent they think the president's a
legitimate
so you know getting people to talk about
threats to democracy was a lift and I
feel like that lift really did
um allow us to to uh have a winning
message for the midterm that could
survive a midterm effect but at the end
of the day David I do think it was
reversal of Roe that provided a concrete
um application of loss of Freedom threat
to democracy because you know many of
our folks especially are not as Keen to
run on abstract hyperbolic abstraction
right so I think it really did help at
the at the campaign level
um in Michigan and Arizona and other
places uh provided a very clear wedge
like a clearly defined issue to Define
freedom and threaten democracy around so
I don't know that we would have had the
success that we had without Roe doing
um you know aggravating our side of the
Coalition
the two
Marie Trump justices it was a trump
court and if you connect those two
things this illegitimate person who
tried to overthrow the Constitution also
packed the court with people who tossed
out a fundamental constitutional right
and those two things were not hard to
connect if people made the argument well
I think I think you're both I I think
you're both right in that um in that you
you've got
democracy and the threat to democracy
but it showed the proof in the pudding
of what the threat to democracy was it
was hey they're going to take away not
just your your government but they're
going to take away your rights your
human rights your women's rights that
maybe you're right to vote I mean where
does it end and they only proved in
Arizona for example where Kerry Lake
lost because of gen Z their first
reaction was well take away their right
to vote and it's like well that is the
reason why they voted you out and and I
think the Democracy uh transcended um
not just through Roe and not just
through January 6 but the Republican
party is not for democracy they are the
threat to democracy and I believe that
that showed in the election don't you
Rachel
absolutely I mean you know I mean here's
us because us broadly speaking people
trying to win elections for you know
keep Republicans out of power hey
Republicans if they get power they're
going to steal your freedom and then
they go they use the one thing of
government they control the time to do
it for us right so like it literally was
the perfect
you know it was the perfect you know
manifestation of the of the argument
that we were making about Republicans so
um and it's still going to be the main
focal point of 2024 because you know the
this is a party that took women's
Freedom away and is coming for the rest
of ours right so we um we are really
going to be pounding threat to democracy
uh and loss of freedom and and the
specific abortion issue uh Roe and
freedom
um all the way through for 2024.
the unifying word is freedom
freedom to vote freedom of uh bodily
autonomy or you know a woman's right
shoes whatever whatever phrase but it is
freedom and you know they've owned
Freedom this has been the Republicans
thing it's it's you're taking away our
guns we're free to do all of these
things and you're trying to limit our
freedoms uh vaccines all the rest now we
own freedom
because we are the party of freedom and
that's that's going to be a distinction
that I think will have a real difference
if if we claim that work we gave it we
let them take it it's ours I I think I
think you're right David and um Rachel I
I know that you have a limited time here
do you have one last thought for us and
David if you will stick around um if
you've got time to do some more
commentary I'm I'm gonna go to some
legal commentary here but Rachel give us
your one last thought
I mean it's just tremendous work from
this committee it will go down in my
opinion as the most effective committees
that we've had since Nixon era and of
course that committee can be more
effective because we had two sane
political parties at that time period
and a pretty stable democracy so you
know when you when you look at what what
the work of this committee was it was to
make sure that it was really clear that
January 6 wasn't a tour of the capital
it wasn't spontaneous it wasn't it was a
coup plot designed to overthrow the
government a multi-stage multi-faceted
multi-involved members all across the
entire you know Republican ecosystem
from local down in up to National
conspiracy to end American democracy and
it probably only failed at the end of
the day because we deployed they
de-platform Trump off of Twitter I mean
I think for me what I would leave people
with is that after Jan said X the effort
continued to get Donald Trump not to
transfer power to Joe Biden after
January 6 okay January
's Dean sitting members of our Congress
in the Republican Party were texting the
white house chief of staff you don't get
more direct to the president than the
whcos okay and telling him declare
martial law
we will never know if Donald Trump had
remained on Twitter if he had would have
done so but I am convinced that his ass
access to the megaphone that was Twitter
for him would have been critical for him
to see success in that pathway because
he would have been able to you know tell
people to take guns and go kill their
neighbors too
the difference is that we can spell
martial law
they couldn't
January 17th and there was a megaphone
um Rachel
what you did by the way just for the
record I know the work you were doing in
this last six months uh really working
hard thank you for that
uh dude I'm just so grateful for
everybody that that listens to me Tony
for platforming me David for you you to
lend your own credibility to my name
because honestly about all of you guys
and all of the people on Twitter I would
have never been able to do what I did on
this midterm effect I would not have had
the access and the influence to do so
and have people trust me to do things
that were very out of the normal
Playbook so you know I I am nothing
without the trust that people like you
and others have put in me so thank you
well we are we are nothing uh without
you Rachel you are the um the lead in
the Democratic
democracy messaging and narrative uh you
have a certain way of saying it you know
I have a certain way of saying things
and I feel like that is our and that is
our true connection thank you thank you
Dr Rachel covered David stick around
um I'll bring you in here really soon
happy New Year Rachel
uh everyone um I'm gonna bring a legal
analysis in with the legal a effers uh
we've got Michael popock and Karen
agnipolo KFA here joining us from legal
AF how are you how's it going over there
Tony hey uh Michael um Karen I think you
have are you limited on time here
yeah
well um Michael I you know we're gonna
let ladies go first so I'm gonna get her
immediate reaction
um for the what what we just witnessed
with the January 6th select hearing of
course we knew a lot of this was going
to happen we we kind of got word from
the journalists who were watching the
rehearsals they kind of knew what they
were rehearsing so it was it was a kind
of but but there's one thing Karen that
I want to ask you about because you know
Jack Smith and you know
um what kind of prosecutor he is now
we have not seen the Hope Hicks video
um until today the part of that
testimony
that piece of evidence if if hope Hicks
is telling the truth which I believe she
is Michael Cohen says she's a very
honest person he believed that she
probably is
do you think that this referral and that
evidence is going to affect Jack Smith's
work and how he's going to pick apart
the evidence to see these criminal
referrals as something that he's going
to use or do you think he's going to
drive his own conclusions from the
evidence
hi so uh criminal referrals are just
basically ceremonial they're not
necessary and they are not usually done
except in certain crimes that are
committed against Congress directly like
things like if if somebody refuses to
provide evidence or testify so you know
this type of criminal referral is is
very is largely ceremonial and however I
believe it was important to do given the
important work that the committee has
done and the testimony that that they
have developed and
um and so I do think it's important that
Apologize by dogs barking that they do
uh that they do do this and so that they
can go on record as a as this is what
they found at the end of their thousands
of witnesses and documents and that's
exactly what they will have done by
going on record and by making these
referrals the criminal investigation has
already been ongoing
Jack Smith who's an excellent prosecutor
who I've worked with personally who's
non-partisan and who's the real deal he
did not need this what he needs is the
committee to turn over all of their
evidence all of their witness statements
and everything they have and he will
look at it he will make his own
independent conclusion and if if the
facts lead to a crime having occurred
Beyond a reasonable doubt now don't
forget a criminal standard is a high bar
and so sometimes even though there is
evidence that so for example uh one of
the things that they refer to in the
committee was the um in the John Eastman
case which was Judge Carter who said it
was more likely than not that a couple
that certain crimes were committed so
more likely than not is a civil standard
that's the preponderance of evidence
standard but the criminal standard is
beyond a reasonable doubt so until and
unless Jack Smith can find that any
crime were committed Beyond a reasonable
doubt he cannot bring criminal charges
so that's what he's looking for and
that's what he's going to be doing by
going through all of this evidence that
has been developed and other evidence
that Jack Smith is going to be able to
develop himself because he does have
criminal subpoena power and he does have
um and he does have the ability to do
things like execute search warrants
Etc so I think he's going to develop
even more evidence and I think you will
see criminal charges coming against
Donald Trump and others the one thing
and then I'll turn it over to my my
co-host Michael popock that I found
interesting about these criminal
referrals was just with respect to
Donald Trump was number one they
referred four different crimes but what
they didn't refer was seditious
conspiracy which I found somewhat
interesting why they didn't do that the
other thing that I that I thought was
interesting is one of the charges that
they are
um that they that they did refer the
obstruction of an act of Congress or the
obstruction of an official proceeding is
actually under review right now by the
DC circuit another in another case uh
based on what the Department of Justice
has charged many of the rioters about
whether or not that's applicable in the
January 6th case and that's you know
that's going to go potentially to the
full DC circuit and potentially to the
Supreme Court so that is even in
question about that that particular
charge is potentially even in question
about whether or not that can be used
with regard to January 6. so those were
sort of the two comments that I wanted
to make about the particular charges but
in general like I said this was a
largely ceremonial but important last
step in the in the select committee's
work and I thought the opening
statements especially the first two by
Benny Thompson and Liz Cheney were you
know they gave me the Goosebumps you
know it's just from uh from a patriotic
kind of you know wrap yourself in the
flag sort of way and I give him a lot of
credit they've done great work so let me
ask you real quick before we go to
popock
um you know Jack Smith personally so the
question is does he really eat nails for
breakfast we were trying to uh determine
this earlier I didn't know if he ate
bowls of nails he looks like a guy who
eats nails for breakfast okay I was just
she's actually he's actually let me just
tell you he's actually a really nice
person she's very unassuming he's not
kind of you know he's just a nice guy
you know he's just he's he's a he's a
nice guy who isn't um like I said I have
no idea what his politics even are he's
an athlete he was a triathlete you know
so he's pretty hardcore and he's just a
cop he's a balls and Strikes caller you
know he he's never had an agenda other
than searching for the truth and Seeking
Justice and and that was always his
reputation you know he just believes in
doing the right thing and he's a true
public servant so he is he is definitely
the the right guy for the job and I
think he's gonna he also just one other
thing he knows how to he knows how to
build cases which is an important skill
set for a prosecutor it's not enough to
just know how to investigate you have to
know how to also build a case and put it
together and he is a case maker so if
there's a case to be made Jack Smith can
do it and will do it well great I'm I'm
Brett's in The Green Room I'm glad we
got confirmation then he only looks like
he eats nails for Rick if he doesn't
actually eat nails or regular toading
Michael popock yeah go ahead what is
your main reaction to the hearing go
ahead I'm going to clarify something
that Karen just said I think he eats
lightning and he craps Thunder oh okay
well that that may for those that are
wrong maybe not males okay those that
are from my generation they'll
understand where I was going with that
um you want to start with you want to
start with the hearing today well yeah
what what is your main what is your red
yeah go ahead I want to pick up a thread
with my co-anchor because because she
she threw it in there but I want people
to understand while I admire everything
about the Gen 6 committee and what
they've done in now nine sessions or ten
sessions gavel to gavel
and yes
um the way everything was presented
being dealt the hand that they were
dealt by a Republican party that refused
to participate in a bipartisan fashion
the way that they did in watercate left
them no choice but then to go down this
format which was very powerful and very
effective yes there wasn't
cross-examination there weren't as many
live Witnesses you know if you look at
old tapes from Watergate in the 70s
what the American people had available
to them now or then but having said that
given the hand that they were dealt I
think they did a masterful job I think
we're all going to be supremely blown
away by their reporting however the I do
have one bone to pick with the Gen 6
committee go ahead you heard them say at
the very end off of emotion by Jamie
Raskin who again as we had hoped it
would be it would be Jamie Raskin doing
the criminal referral part of the
presentation Professor Raskin
constitutional law professor Raskin and
it was however
he said permission I'm paraphrasing to
Benny Thompson as the chair permission
to send to the Department of Justice
relevant portions of our material in
support of the criminal referrals that
we're making wrong
all of the material I see my former
prosecutor current anchor is nodding her
head all of the material that they have
developed should have already frankly in
parallel been turned over to the
Department of Justice months ago to
allow them to step into the shoes of the
John 6 committee and progress that
forward instead it's a little-known
reporting we've done it on legal AF that
there has been Turf War and a tug of war
between the Gen 6 committee and the
Department of Justice right before Jack
Smith was appointed by in a big press
conference with Merrick Garland the
other major thing Merrick Garland did
was like make another Demand on the Jan
6 committee publicly to turn over their
1000 plus witness statements some under
oath some not hundreds of thousands of
pages of documents and turn that over
now having said that the Department of
Justice has even though they get a lot
of grief for their the the the velocity
at which people think they're operating
which I don't think is reality I think
they're operating at such a higher level
of velocity almost the human eye can't
catch how fast they're moving and we
think they're not moving at all right
it's like that hummingbird whose wings
move so quickly people don't think it's
moving the wings aren't moving at all
they're moving rapidly and now turbo
charged with with uh Karen's former
colleague Jack Smith they have developed
not the best evidence yet but a better
quality of evidence that the Department
of Justice because in the last three
months and in the last two months
they've been able to do that which the
Gen 6 committee has never been able or
or is not empowered to do which is to
force lawyers and members of The West
Wing to drop their attorney client and
an executive privilege and testify
compelled testimony there's only so much
the Gen 6 committee can do members of
Congress that decided they did not want
to go to the Gen 6 committee they didn't
go to the Gen 6 committee and they'll
get maybe they'll get censured by
January 2nd before the new Congress
comes in or maybe they won't but that's
about it a couple of motions for a
couple of referrals for contempt the
Department of Justice took up but the
Department of Justice in the last three
months in judge Barrel Howell's
courtroom the judge overseeing the chief
judge overseeing all grand juries that
Jack Smith is now responsible for has
methodically Stripped Away all
attorney-client privilege and all
executive privilege forcing these people
to testify to the grand jury so the
quality of evidence and that's I think a
number of the members of today's
committee referenced it even Jamie
Raskin referenced it that that there is
more that the Department of Justice has
to connect the dots than even the Gen 6
committee was able to do because of
people refusing to testify the other
staggering thing besides the obvious
Donald J Trump former president
four you know three or four different
crimes including the crime of
insurrection which takes them out of the
running from ever being uh forget about
running for office he couldn't run for
office constitutionally but to hear the
witness tampering again which must have
sent a chill down Karen's spine as a
former prosecutor you've got the Trump
people paying for lawyers to tamper with
witness testimony to to try to convince
them not to remember things that they
remembered not to re this is a breach by
the way of the of the every lawyer's
ethical and professional responsibility
duties when a client asks a lawyer who's
paying you you have to answer you can't
say my advice is being compromised
because I'm getting paid by Donald Trump
to represent you when it is you have to
reveal that you have to disclose that
that is fundamentals to the bar that's
why so many lawyers are going to get
disbarred all around this all around
Trump and and offering them jobs
offering Witnesses jobs if they play in
the sandbox right and don't testify
against Donald Trump as the committee
and the Department of Justice searches
for the truth the Department of Justice
can't has got to be unhappy uh and
towards Donald Trump and others in
hearing the witness tampering aspect we
haven't focused on it because there's so
much other crimes and facts to focus on
but witness tampering is a really bad
thing and if and if they if the John 6
committee is already divided Tony's
laughing well I mean I mean obstruction
obstruction and and witness tampering
piss prosecutors uh probably more than
anything else that you could do in their
investigation what I loved about and and
Karen touched on it what I loved about
Liz Cheney who basically may have
sacrificed her career in elected office
forever more because of her standing up
as a States person and doing the right
thing now people you can you can you can
have a legitimate debate about Liz
Cheney and her morals and her politics
before this moment but there is no
question there is no question that she
committed potentially political suicide
forevermore
in order to protect our democracy and to
serve in the high profile the highest
profile position really other than Benny
on the on the uh the Gen 6 committee and
when she started off she wrote her own
you know people say oh Ari melber was
involved who cares
she wrote her own opening and her
opening statement her closing statement
leading off with her great great
grandfather
who is on the union side of the Civil
War
and what the historian that followed
that that voluntary uh regiment in Ohio
what they what he said about those
people like her great great grandfather
and why they they served and her great
grandfather apparently was in all four
years of the Civil War and actually
marched down Pennsylvania Avenue to be
greeted not by Lincoln because of his
assassination but by the uh successor to
Lincoln Johnson and U.S Grant to hear
her put that in context and talk about
the murals and paintings in the capitol
about George Washington which is
supposed to be the blueprint the DNA
impressed on every president when he
takes office and the peaceful transfer
of power it was you know it made then
and there it made me proud again to be
an American that we have a process that
allows the Gen 6 committee to do its
work and to make presentations to the
American people and now releasing not
just their report but it sounds like
they're going to be releasing lots of
things I just wanted them to release
faster to the doj so they could move on
their prosecutions even quicker than
they're able to do well I I think um I
think that the the speed of it is
important but I actually don't believe
we'll even get to a trial until after
the 2024 election maybe I'm crazy and
I'm just doing the math in my head and
how long it takes and the can kicking
down the road and then if he does become
the nominee in the process
um that even kicks the can further past
so we have to have be focused on
democracy we have to be focused on
public opinion but I want to go to one
opinion here because I want to get a
response a quick response from both of
you of this clip we played it earlier in
our previous
um our our pre-game coverage here as it
were for the hearing but the former vice
president Mike Pence went on the um Fox
News Network I don't know if you know it
as news I don't but that's what they
call it the fly on his head did not
appear this morning but Mike Pence did
and he had a legal take that I want you
to to respond quickly to what you think
rather you know is legal or illegal
let's watch when it comes to the Justice
Department's decision about about
um about bringing charges in the future
I would hope that they would not bring
charges against the former president I I
don't look I as I wrote in my book I
think the president's actions and words
on January 6 were Reckless
but I don't know that it's it's criminal
to take bad advice from lawyers
um you're both lawyers is it criminal to
um
act on bad advice from lawyers is that
is that could that be illegal I don't
know I'm just you know it seems like it
could be Karen go ahead
well first of all that assumes the fact
you know not necessarily in evidence I
don't necessarily think he assumed he
relied on bad advice from lawyers I
think he went and looked for lawyers who
would let him have his theory and would
say oh well maybe you could do one thing
or another so if that were in fact true
that he relied on legal advice from
lawyers I I suppose that makes it a
little trickier but that's just
ridiculous so and and there's also
something called the you know I I think
I think his lawyers were co-conspirators
uh not not actual legal advice yeah to
Karen to Karen's Point Jamie Raskin the
only other name that Donald Trump
mentioned that Jamie draskin mentioned
other than Donald Trump was John Eastman
who is John Eastman remind everyone who
John so John Eastman was this too smart
by half attorney
their in-house constitutional scholar
Professor Dr John Eastman from you look
like Donald Trump Jr now because you're
putting a lot of quotes around that
would be a different motion with my
fingers Donald Trump Jr
um who who uh Johnny's men who was a uh
affiliated with a real reasonably small
law school named Chapman University out
in California which to be frank I'd
never heard of and was the brains I mean
this is I'm really using these terms
Loosely the brains behind the operation
for both the fake elector Scandal
um coming up with let's have fake
electors and let's let's nominate them
and also the theory
which got all the way to Pence that Mike
Pence as the vice president had
something other than just ministerial
acts to count the votes and certify the
election and the peaceful transfer of
power that Mike Pence could stop the
peaceful transfer of power could throw
the election to the house and away from
the electors allow the house dominated
by Republicans or house legislatures
it's legislative slates which were
dominated by Republicans to throw the
election to Donald Trump I mean I feel
like I'm talking about stuff in the
1800s that used to almost happen you
know uh but this was John Eastman and
this was the fight there's a clip they
showed today of of Karen knows that he's
my favorite lawyer former Trump lawyer
because he's just so profane you'd like
him too Tony because I like profanity he
uses the F-bomb a lot but it's the
lawyer whose name will come to me in a
minute that works for Mark kazowitz's
firm
um uh who was in The White House Karen
what's it do you remember his name
Hershman and he and Hershman said to
John Eastman when John Eastman ran these
theories about Mike Pence by Hershman
Hershman said two things that will for
well they'll be in great they'll be Inc
uh uh engraved or carved on his
headstone uh at us when he dies the
first one was after he heard Johnny
Smith's ramblings of a Madman he said I
have repeat after me
peaceful transfer of power and Johnny
Smith like and he said no stop say those
words and he made John Eastman say
peaceful transfer of power and he said
now I'm going to give you the best effin
advice you'll ever be given get yourself
a TR a great effin criminal defense
lawyer because you're gonna need it they
showed that last clip today a little bit
out of context to Jan six
um and of course he's already testified
without without executive privilege or
without attorney-clined privilege to the
grand juries as has as has Pat Uh sip
alone so John Eastman is also the
subject of something else that Raskin
talked about today because remember John
Eastman on his own apparently with no
support from Donald Trump whatsoever or
his band of lawyers was fighting against
the Jan 6 committee about turning over
his emails claiming they were
attorney-climb privilege or claiming
they were yeah mainly attorney client
privilege and the Jan 6 committee with
Jamie Raskin talked about in his
presentation today how to go to court in
the central district of California in
front of Judge Carter remember that
judge Carter and did something no other
committee like this has ever done which
has got a judge a federal judge looking
at the evidence first determined that
John Eastman was not did not have the
attorney client or work product or
litigation privilege because it was
likely that he was involved in a
criminal conspiracy and so the crime
fraud exception it's just stunning the
crime fraud exception would apply
meaning all of his emails between him
and Trump and the others are not covered
by the privilege because he was
participating in a crime or new or
should have known it was a participation
in a crime judge Carter went on to say
that there was there was not at the
criminal prosecution standard of Beyond
a reasonable doubt maybe not even
probable cause but close to it judge
Carter said Eastman and Trump likely
committed at least two crimes including
the obstruction one that they talked
about today to the committee so so
Eastman
um it's gonna get listened we always
thought he was going to be the Fall Guy
but it's not just him and following John
Eastman or following Boris Epstein or
following uh Sydney Powell or Rudy
Giuliani who's also in tremendous Harm's
Way not only here but in the fawnee
Willis investigation and the parallel
Department of Justice investigation out
of Georgia election interference
um you know all of the if these lawyers
are providing you just what you want to
hear in order to give you cover for your
crime that doesn't count if the lawyers
are involved in the criminal conspiracy
that doesn't count
and a lot of these it doesn't matter if
there is a Reliance on Council Karen can
speak this better than me Reliance on
Council is not a defense to many crimes
where willfulness or intentional or
corrupt corruptly is the standard for
the crime it sounds like to me and I've
got to go to some other commentators
here it sounds like to me that if you're
co-conspiring as a lawyer to commit
crimes with your client it's still crime
it sounds like that is the conclusion so
everyone go go check out legal AF on the
Midas Dutch Network subscribe right here
if you're on there now you'll see legal
AF
um and Karen thank you for joining us
popoc thank you as well uh we'll we'll
see you we'll see you soon my friends
thank you bye bye Tony take care see you
tomorrow
um so I'm gonna go to Jessica Denson and
uh David Bender here and then we will
follow up and uh me Gabe Sanchez in
Texas Paul we're gonna close this
coverage out uh in in great style here
but I want to bring Jessica Denson back
and David Bender hello
um I'm glad you guys stuck around for a
few minutes
um and I know you guys had some comments
for the commentary that has been going
on so Jessica let me start with you uh
and then David will will
um go to you Jessica
you've been listening to the commentary
here what have you found most
interesting about the takes that we have
here on the Midas touch network of the
coverage
and and also the hearing and some of
these either the legal or the the court
of public opinion Maybe
well so many so many threads to pick up
on here since I have my fellow Freedom
Fighter with me David I will I will pick
up on that thread because I think it
really
um it will bring me into a major point
that I want to make yes the Democrats
led by candidates like Josh Shapiro
really took back the banner of freedom
and I I talk about this endlessly
because it is that one that one human
need that we all have for freedom the
Republicans have hijacked for so long it
was most certainly what kept me
wrongfully misled on their in in support
of them for so long was thinking that
they were the party of Freedom thank God
that we are finally waking up to the
fact that they're not just not the party
of Freedom they're the party of
authoritarianism they're the party of
dictatorship they want to dismantle
everything that keeps us free
um and so yes Amen to Democrats
reclaiming that and really I hope um you
know the other candidates that sort of
took some more Niche issues to run on
really look at candidacies like Josh
Shapiro's and see what a winning
strategy that was
um it's such a universal it such it has
such a universal appeal and it's the
truth the Democrats own it
um on that line of of the Democrats
owning freedom and representing it and
the Republicans being really the party
of dictatorship and authoritarianism I
think what we have to really brace
ourselves for as indictments come and I
think they I I I expect them to come
they must come if if our democracy is to
survive Donald Trump must be indicted
the evidence is there
um we have to brace ourselves for these
these gaslit narratives that are going
to be coming especially with Kevin
McCarthy and the Republicans controlling
the House of Representatives there are
going to be all kinds of false
equivalencies made between Trump and his
corrupt criminal family and Hunter Biden
you know you're going to hear this
you're going to hear Biden crime family
this obscene statement that couldn't be
farther from the truth and you're you're
going to see in the media a tendency as
um as far from the truth as it may be
for them to play into these false
equivalencies and just act like we have
political forces on two sides arguing
that both sides are corrupt we have to
be in constant narrative correction mode
to clarify who really did the factually
criminal behavior and and understand why
prosecution of that criminal behavior is
appropriate versus political political
attacks and persecutions that really
come from the Republicans although they
are always accusing the Democrats of
being the political persecutors and I
just I'm gonna have to jump here soon so
I'm going to Loop back to what Michael
was saying Michael Cohen in the
beginning of this post coverage he was
talking about the political persecution
of the doj under Trump and this is so
vital to to never forget because the
Republicans will try to cast this
upcoming um these upcoming indictments
as political we never had a more
politically motivated corruptly
um influential on a justice department
president than Donald Trump persecuting
his perceived enemies trying to silence
them I of course live through this
having my livelihood threatens nearly
facing bankruptcy for expressing the
truth and My First Amendment rights as
it pertained to a sitting president in
his campaign nobody ever violated free
speech freedom and weaponized the
justice department and prosecution of
his enemies more than Donald Trump and
this party his Republican party defended
that they are the political persecutor
let's keep it straight
and Jessica uh fellow fellow Freedom
Fighter that's a great phrase actually
the more I think about it if if we could
get people to start calling themselves
Freedom Fighters as Democrats that we
are the Freedom Fighters that's a phrase
and it you won't usually hear a Democrat
go out and say I'm a freedom fighter but
if we start saying that about ourselves
it becomes true it happens to have the
convenience of being true but that is a
phrase that it absolutely States the
case for where we are now we are
fighting for Freedom it's being
threatened in one case it specifically
has been taken away a very visceral
reaction uh was manifested in the
elections freedom fighting is what we
have to do now so you know I'm not
saying we have to Don gorilla outfits
and look like Che Guevara but we are in
fact Freedom Fighters it's a spiritual
warfare spiritual weapons
but it is factual freedom fighting that
we're doing I'm glad you used afraid
because I'm gonna I'm gonna not steal it
but I'm gonna share it with you oh you
just do it let's do it David I I wonder
I want to read one thing uh it was seven
hours ago the Cheeto dusk q and honor as
I referred to him and Donald Trump who
is now uh criminally referred from the
January 6 elect committee to the doj
he posts this on his fraud social
network he says election interference by
the FBI and Twitter was massive and
determinative how sad this is the
gaslighting that Jessica was talking
about and what we have to battle against
um and Jessica give us one last thought
because the gas lining has I mean the
machine the chaos machine as I call it
is on the chaos machine is on it's
running it'll keep running it's not
going to stop running
um we have to be vigilant we have to
lean into democracy whether you call it
Freedom Fighters the pro-democracy
Coalition whatever it is I believe that
we must in this country do what
democracies do and that is democracy
itself so tell us tell us about this
gaslighting because I know you've
experienced this but what's your
reaction there of course that was his
statement before the uh the Select
Committee hearing today and of course he
keeps he keeps posting on about Twitter
and how he was cheated of course and you
know continuing the big lie which we
know from from Hope Hicks testimony
which there's another there's another
woman who has stood before and told the
truth about Donald Trump
um which again and again it's a woman
that that does this that has the courage
um you know some of the White House
attorneys some of the White House
counsel these men didn't have the
courage to testify they pled the fifth
over and over and over again but but um
I digress so tell me the the the the the
gaslighting with Twitter and why it is
so important to stay vigilant as we
Freedom fight pro-democracy lean into
democracy tell us yeah gaslighting well
remember this when you think about
gaslighting and the propaganda of the
Fox News is the oan the real America
news this is Russian propaganda this is
authoritarian propaganda
101. it is not just
um you know gaslighting what is
gaslighting we hear this word so much
it's it's making people question their
own sanity and the effect that it has is
it literally pervert presents an
inverted image Up Is Down In This World
freedom is dictatorship political
persecution is Justice everything is
upside down it's like this this debacle
this spectacle that we have going on
with Twitter right now when I mean I
tweeted the other day do people finally
get it Eli was never for free speech
Trump was never for free speech the GOP
was never for free speech and they they
allowed them to hold these banners for
so long saying oh elon's a free speech
absolutist give me a break he was never
a free speech at salutist do you know
how many Republicans spoke out against
Donald Trump's ndas that he was his
illegal ndas that he was using to gag
people for life when I was fighting
these ndas and still M how many
Republicans
of course zero did Elon Musk ever rail
against the assaults on free speech from
Donald Trump and his illegal ndas never
of course he didn't of course well I'm
sure Elon Musk was jealous of his ndas
it was was quite jealous of his ndas uh
Jessica how much time do you have left I
do have to dance I wanna I just want a
couple of things um here you know
notwithstanding as Pope bug point out
raskin's little uh misstep there in the
end of the committee these I I just have
so much appreciation and gratitude for
these committee members for Liz Cheney
for rep Lauria who lost her seat for
representative Murray and Lofgren and
kinzinger
um who am I leaving out here I don't
want to leave anybody out but these
these public servants have just been
exemplary models of Courage of dignity
of Integrity uh representative Raskin I
will never forget in 2020 I was in
Georgia I'm working to get um Warnock
and also elected the first time and I
heard the news of
his son who he lost and just just to
remember how he had put has put that
pain to purpose this this eloquent I
heard somebody say on television the
other day that representative Raskin is
almost too eloquent or too elegant for
for cable news this man is such a model
for all of us and I'm so grateful for
the work he's done and speaking of women
will bring it back to women the tour de
force that is house Speaker outgoing
house Speaker Nancy Pelosi never forget
how she constructed this committee this
was supposed to be an independent
commission the Republicans um you know
sabotage that effort and Nancy Pelosi
deathly with all of the skill that she
has did not allow this to become a
circus with people like Jim Jordan
sitting on it she took back the reins
and look at this beautiful
bipartisan committee that she
constructed the truth that they have
brought out the light that has shown
forth
um we we as a people have so much a debt
of gratitude to um Nancy Pelosi to this
committee to the Republicans too if
they're only two that stood and put
their careers on the line and
um put the truth out for the American
people in the world well thank you
Jessica for joining us and I think
you're right women are going to save
democracy they will save the world and
frankly yes men have messed it up long
enough so we should just turn it over to
them then if you want my personal
opinion speak for yourself
to go happy New Year thank you so much
thank you happy Hanukkah Merry Christmas
and happy New Year everybody freedom in
absolutely we're going to do it we'll
talk to you soon my friend David Bender
I want to ask you
um the court because today was the court
of public opinion really right that's
what it was yeah right it wasn't a
criminal court today there wasn't actual
criminal charges it was just a referral
from us right this is this is what I try
to get my viewers to understand that we
are the government it is us it is the
people
um we are a democratic constitutional
republic which means that we elect
democratically through the Constitution
our representatives to go vote in our
place but it is our vote it is us and
Donald Trump clearly we knew this in the
time when it was happening but the
selectivity has done such a great job at
laying out the evidence for the public
telling the story of the Cheeto dust
kangaroo coup as I call it but his
subversion of our vote it was him trying
to take away our vote and our
constitutional right to that vote and
make our voice heard through the
government and when these
Representatives as Jessica put it uh
speak rather they're republican or
democrat or rather it's speaker Pelosi
which they all deserve credit
um but they are us they are standing
there for us and our voice speaking of
freedom and constitutional government
but tell me about the court of public
opinion because the government the
people right the people need to hear
um that Donald Trump will possibly be
criminally charged by the Department of
Justice and I believe that was really
their goal today is to make sure to get
into the court of public opinion that
this is going to happen this is a
possibility
well Mr chairman if if I can request
three minutes go ahead go ahead yes if
the gentleman were yield I will you I uh
I do think that the fundamental thing
that we saw today and this is where I
would park company from Mr popoc I I
don't fault Raskin at all I think that
what they are doing is they're supplying
all of the information so it has has to
go up on Wednesday or by the end of this
week
just firm will have everything they have
they're sending over specific referrals
they only name two people they named uh
Donald John Trump they named John
Eastman there are others we now know and
I was looking at my notes uh here uh we
now know that the four members of
Congress who will be referred to the
Ethics Committee are Kevin McCarthy Jim
Jordan Scott Perry and Andy Brooks Andy
Biggs yes uh Mo Brooks no longer member
of Congress or he would be so those four
are going up for ethics charges whether
anything happens or not the point is
this is the court of public opinion and
what Jessica said is quite right we've
been through an era of gaslighting you
know why that's going to end or it's
going to it's going to be far harder for
them to do
because now we have a special prosecutor
in Jack Smith who is absolutely unafraid
to bring charges and he will ultimately
with Merrick Garland's approval decide
whether or not to indict
Donald John Trump not president Trump
Donald Trump private citizen right uh as
a potential felon as an insurrectionist
did they they did not go with seditious
conspiracy a harder a higher bar and
again I'm not a lawyer but I can look at
the history of this a hard charge to
prove but in this case
they charged him with Insurrection
aiding and comforting the overthrow of
the government of the United States our
government to your point Mr chairman our
government is a representative we are a
republic so we elect our representatives
there to represent our interests if
they're not doing that
if Jim Jordan is not doing that Scott
Perry is not doing that if all of these
people who are sending messages in
talking about how we have to declare
martial law uh these people themselves
should be held to a higher standard
Michael Moore to his great credit put up
121 members of the House who at any
point have aided and abetted this
Insurrection through their votes through
their statements these people are not
fit to serve and then if if if some of
them ultimately are either removed
through a court of law or they're
removed in the next election because
they're insurrectionists
then we will no longer have you know a
five margin Republican vote and good
luck to Kevin McCarthy holding that
caucus together but the truth is what we
have seen today was the most important
thing we could see after a year and a
half this well the committee started in
June you recall we talked about this
going in how important it would be if
they could move
the court of public opinion
they did that that's what we saw in all
these public hearings culminating in
today we had a 10-minute video that we
capped it all I bet you that's going to
go viral I assume you're going to play
it at some point that video tells the
story of a case that the public needed
to understand
is much larger than than what will
ultimately be the accountability in in a
court of law a lot of Courts of law
Fulton County uh the Manhattan D.A is
finally going to possibly do justice to
what uh Michael Cohen went through
because conspirator number one uh
defendant the unnamed one in Stormy
Daniels that's Donald Trump so in every
single one of these
cases potentially
Donald Trump is criminally liable
accountable and he you know I I heard
you say it might not happen until after
2024. tell you what will happen before
that we want to get a conviction we will
certainly go out on appeal we'll have
the cases brought to a court oh
absolutely 23. I I believe I believe we
will have indictments
um sometimes sometime early next year
um I'd like to have an early Christmas
present but I don't know why
it's possible it's possible
um but I I know how the justice system
works in the federal end and I I know
that the timing of this is only is only
to kick the can pass to trial pass the
election uh Donald Trump knows that's
why he's running that's why he's running
for president he's not running for
Brands to Stave off an indictment he
wants to fend off a trial before 2024
that's what he's trying to do that's my
guess
um motivation it's not it's not going to
work with more to the point what's going
to happen in 2023 is this will come
before judges they will start having
trials this will happen in real time and
for many of these other people as well
any of the co-conspirators the giulianis
and the fake electors and all these
people are going to behold in front of
Courts and that that's going to keep
this on the front burner and the
Republican party is going to turn its
back you know they're they're really
tired of winning the Republican party
they remember Trump's promise you're
going to get so tired of winning well
they're tired of winning right because
they haven't won a thing and they're
going to turn their back and I I do
think the point that Michael Cohen made
at the very outset of this coverage is
that there are other mini trunks tiny
little tiny tiny little Rhonda Santos uh
is a danger he's he's got his own
Napoleonic complex and he is going to
try and take this same gas lighting and
Big Y stuff
without the baggage of trump so you know
this battle this battle for freedom is
not anywhere near one uh but we saw what
happened
with these midterms you and I haven't
spoken since then we saw what happens
when people have a chance to vote on
this unfortunately so many of these
people uh people like Biggs and go star
and others some didn't even have
opponents there were no Democrats
running it it it's time that we said
that bright red districts can be flipped
if it's over the question of did you
support the overthrow of the government
I I agree wholeheartedly and I think the
court of public opinion um will see what
is today and like I said before in the
earlier coverage Americans will believe
um you know wrongly that Donald Trump
was actually indicted on criminal
charges today that's just how
information Works in our world today
unfortunately
um but I I don't know that that's a bad
thing that may be not a bad thing maybe
right it may be a little bit of the
intention is to convince the American
people that he already is criminally
charged David Bender thank you for
joining us today I appreciate your
commentary always come join the show
come come be back on the podcast
you're back happy New Year happy
holidays to to you and yours and YouTube
be safe be safe and and have a great
holiday we'll talk to you soon my friend
okay thank you thank you
um so I want to bring in my co-host and
then he's he's become our also co-host
on Tuesday Texas Paul but today's Monday
but it is Texas Paul Tuesday all of a
sudden you're on the minus touch Network
and the Tony Michaels podcast fellas how
are you I I know we've had some
technical difficulties and it's been a
it's been a while since um we've been on
the screen uh today so uh Gabe Sanchez
Texas Paul again I know it's usually a
Texas Paul Tuesday but here we are
Monday we're on the minus touch Network
and we have such important stuff to talk
about now that we know Donald Trump is a
criminal officially well at least in the
eyes of the committee which we knew this
we've been talking about this for a long
time actually I want to remind everyone
um while you're here make sure to
subscribe to the minus touch Network
you'll you'll get great videos from
personalities like been my zealous legal
takes on this I'm sure Gabe Sanchez uh
you're probably already writing uh what
was that and then Texas Paul is
definitely going to be at the cussing
Pond I'm sure um within the next you
know five six he's always at the cussing
Pond what am I talking about
um but go ahead and subscribe also to
our channel the Tony Michaels podcast
you don't want to miss a single episode
tomorrow we will have Texas ball back on
as long as it's not worn out from today
um for Texas Paul Tuesday we do every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch we do two
full hours of commentary Tuesdays just
happens to be the day that Texas Paul
joins us but again it feels like Tuesday
you're here Texas ball what was your
immediate reaction what was your
immediate reaction Texas followed this
of this meeting
I was just thinking about what it's got
to be like down in Mar-A-Lago today
Donald Trump is ass is in a crack I mean
it isn't so deep in that crack I mean
just are you talking about his ass crack
or what are you talking about I wanted I
wanted to finish yes this is how it
works he is so screwed we got 18 USC
1512 which carries a maximum of three
years for obstruction and tampering we
know there's going to be multiple counts
of that you've got uh uh USC 371 which
carries a Max of five years the
conspiracy of the commit offension
defrauding the the government there'll
be at least one count of that probably
more uh a thousand one the Martha
Stewart
um uh statute
um she went to jail for five months over
a thousand and one line lying to Federal
investigators
he's looking at a Max of eight years
because this involved terrorism mm-hmm
he's looking at a Max of eight years on
that one charge alone and and this is
the worst case scenario you know they're
charging him with Insurrection the
symptoms saying you know normally you
hear about these Federal sentencing
guidelines and they're like super high
and you're like oh my God you know he
only got six months when there was 12 on
12 years on the table Yeah but this is
worst case scenario folks he pushes the
needle on those sentencing guidelines
way the hell up there way the hell out
there and then of course we've got the
sexual and Insurrection that'll be the
Hard One to prove but this is before we
even start talking about do you say sexy
did you say the X Direction charge is
the sexy one oh that's the one people
are going to eat uh they're gonna eat
that up Resurrection sexy time sexy time
oh my God but before you before you even
get to all of that you've got Kevin
McCarthy Scott Perry Jim Jordan and Andy
Biggs his biggest Stooges are all
[ __ ] they cannot do anything for him
because the Ethics Committee while it
does that does not sound sexy it is by
completely bipartisan they will open an
investigation over this they can't hide
the investigation over this and if they
try to politically they're going to be
so screwed
this is just Donald Trump is dying right
now I would not be surprised I would not
be surprised that when the reality of
this hits in and he gets done you know
posting on all of his [ __ ] websites
that this guy doesn't when reality
finally sits in that he doesn't punch
his his revoke his own life subscription
I mean this guy is not a strong man
you're saying you're saying it might be
um my Epps demons self I guess here here
is actually his most recent response
it's showing about 13 minutes ago I
don't know if he's uh posted again you
gotta you gotta love this what aboutism
unrelated crazy well who gives a [ __ ]
sheet lost who gives a [ __ ] like why why
does why is it so important that he
points out that Liz Cheney lost by a
record 40 points you lost two you weak
piece of [ __ ]
he not only lost once he lost twice two
times in a row and the second time was
more embarrassing because it was more
than double the amount that he lost by
last time right but the guy coming up
and say oh well well
okay so like she's coming at me with
these criminal charges she lost her
election or her prime like who cares
because at the end of the day it doesn't
really matter he's just trying to
distract and be like well what about
what about Liz Cheney in her election
that's unrelated shoot me inside
Insurrection is he trying to say that
she's not a member of Congress because
he knows he knows that she's not member
of Congress on January 3rd right as of
now she still holds the power of of the
congresswoman I don't know what what
he's trying to say here I mean it is
astounding it is astounding that this
and and this is his response
um he's written a little bit about
Twitter here which is you know
I guess interesting at best
um this morning but this is his actual
response 15 minutes ago that lives
Chaney lost my record 40 points that's
his response Texas Paul to the country
now and and I know this sounds crazy
but Texas Paul the majority of people
who are going to hear this news are
going to believe that Donald Trump is
now criminally charged for January 6.
that's the other big thing that that why
he's losing I guarantee you losing his
[ __ ] mind right now he is absolutely
going into orbit is because this there
was they
pop pop was absolutely right there was a
turf war going on between the January 6
committee and the doj the administrator
and the administration they the
administration was saying give us what
you got and give it to us now and and
the January 6 committee said no we're
going to do our thing and we're going to
finish this up and then we'll give it to
you well now they get it all every last
bit of it plus they're going to have
special little packages for all of these
criminal referrals right and man I just
did the quick math on this guys if you
do if he's just facing three counts of
obstruction and hampering okay just
three
he's looking at a Max of about 32 years
oh just this this is before the
documents case before Manhattan let me
tell you something before Georgia I I
don't know how they incarcerate him
because he is a former president we'd
never done that before like we never
crossed that Rubicon so I don't know how
they incarcerate him but I will tell you
I guarantee you Donald Trump at least
gets a dirty 30. and if people out there
don't know what a dirty 30 is that's 20
years hard plus 10 years of Probation
and I don't know that he'll make it
through the Big Macs and buckets of KFC
well I mean
this guy this guy's screwed and when I
talked about this earlier 76 that and
I've been saying it since he ran
that this 76 year old fat slob is not
running for president to fend off
indictments he knows they're coming
Jesus Christ the clip I played of Mike
Pence and I'll play it here in a second
so we get a response Mike Pence knew
that it was going to be Donald Trump and
John Eastman's name today [ __ ] Pence
knew that that's why he was on Fox News
blaming it on the attorney blaming it on
John Eastman as if John Eastman came up
with this whole idea for Donald Trump to
be the [ __ ] dictator or some [ __ ] get
out of here like like Karen and and pop
pop said he was looking for an attorney
who would who wanted him to be the
dictator and give him the reason to be
the dictator Donald Trump only runs on
confirmation bias wow we've seen that
again and again and that's true of his
history he just needs a Yes Man someone
to agree with him someone to say yes you
are right yeah how can I do that and
then we also saw that in I don't forget
maybe it was the fifth one the fifth
hearing that we had uh but it was I
think it was in that one where
he was like hey so what about this Italy
conspiracy and everyone's like that's
not a real thing satellites don't change
the outcome of votes he says yeah but we
need to investigate we need to get uh
Department of Homeland Security we need
to seize these machines people are like
what are you doing why yeah I think it
was Hershman he's like what the [ __ ] and
Hershman Hershman that's some of the
best footage in the testimony too quite
honest with you where he's like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about that is the
most ridiculous thing I have ever heard
in my entire life you're an idiot for
even having that thought in your brain
but it's the same thing that the Italy
satellites the machines being
compromised the the ballot boxes Me 2
000 meals all this nonsense all this Q
Anon garbage is the same thing as what
he just posted not but 20 minutes ago
entry social it's a distraction it's
gaslighting it's what about ISM what
about Liz Cheney like who gives a [ __ ]
about Liz Janey the committee's done man
they done did their job and now there's
criminal referrals which they don't need
them but that's but again I want to go
back to this point they do not need
they do not need a criminal referral
from Congress and and they I mean
Department of Justice in Jacksonville
they do not need a criminal referral to
indict this [ __ ] they do not
need that they don't need a one
now the most important thing is that I'm
telling you when the American people
hear this news that Donald Trump has
been criminally referred to the
Department of Justice they are going to
believe that he has been indicted that's
what they're going to believe regardless
of what you want to think about it or
not that's how information Works in our
country with social media and and the
media in general they are not going to
do a good job of trying to explain how
this works to people and I think the
select committee knows that and I think
that's their intention here is to make
sure to drive public opinion that hey an
expectation more than anything Texas
Paul the expectation is Donald Trump is
criminally charged so when doj and Jack
Smith announce this it's not going to be
a big deal there's not going to be this
unrest that they that he continues to
try to stoke in the stochastic terrorism
that he continues to try to stoke he
thinks his his violent his violent
supporters are going to save him again
and they're not they're just not Texas
ball he can't no no they've seen they've
seen people going to jail they're not
going and and they seem this [ __ ]
Trading Card Griff he the magic spell is
broken on enough of those people
nobody's going to throw their lives away
again but I tell you what they are doing
the Republicans are going on offense if
what they're doing is they're accusing
Jack Smith of being a Democrat and in
the tank uh it's a political uh
prosecution they're saying he's in the
tank for Democrats and the proof they're
offering is that John Edwards wasn't
convicted and if you don't know the
[ __ ] machinations that bring us to
that
I mean I mean my first question is most
people don't even know who [ __ ] John
Edwards is Texas ball because it's been
so goddamn long like who gives a [ __ ]
who John Edwards is who gives a guy good
God damn
Jack Smith head of the public Integrity
division of the doj he was freshly
appointed when the decision was made to
prosecute John Edwards John Kerry's
running mate for taking about a half
million dollars in in in trying to make
sure his wife didn't find out that his
misters listen listen this this this
right here is a good example of how
[ __ ] delusional the Q an honors and
manga is I mean they are absolutely off
their goddamn rockers that they believe
that they can spin this message to be a
working narrative they they are they are
pinned in a corner and there is nothing
they could do listen this John Edwards
narrative is going to go over like a wet
fart and a white thong there's no way
that this is gonna go ahead go ahead but
this is this is the thing they're not
even close to reality on it they're just
making it up as they go They're saying
Jack Smith prosecuted uh John Edwards
and he got away he didn't prosecute him
he wasn't the prosecutor on the case he
didn't prove the case the case approved
by Lenny Brower I don't know if you
remember him he was holder's assistant
everybody was shocked when he approved
it because the case was a [ __ ] wet
dog to begin with they couldn't prove
that the these folks didn't just give
him the money because he was John
Edwards they had to prove that it was
for his campaign we couldn't prove that
and John Denver's made a fool made fools
out of those prosecutors in that trial I
mean he basically openly mocked him in
court when he was winking at women and
[ __ ] and he knew it he knew it and and
again if that's their comparison here
they're really screwed well what's worse
is I mean best actually is it's like
everything else they do they try this
[ __ ] and they end up looking like
[ __ ] because the guy that actually
started the prosecution against John
Edwards and did the investigation was a
guy uh his name was George holding he
was a a federal prosecutor down in North
Carolina
the guy immediately resigns doesn't
prosecute the case and runs as a [ __ ]
Republican for the House of
Representatives
ah wouldn't you know it wouldn't you
know it I mean Gabe Sanchez but we do
this every week though like every
[ __ ] day we do this where we see
these arguments I mean we we literally
went in Texas Paul I can't wait till
tomorrow until we talk about the Trump
trading cards because I know we're going
to get on the subject tomorrow with you
um but here's the thing we went that day
that that [ __ ] dropped what was it 15
minutes before our show started we had a
thumbnail maybe we had a title and the
Trump trading cards dropped and I said
that's what we're doing we're going with
mocking that that just a joke of a thing
and the crazy part is we went through
that day within hours of him announcing
it we went through the website we looked
at it on the show and I've I I was I'm
working on what was that right now for
this because I've found even more stuff
it's worse and worse right it's insane
well and it seems like a money
laundering scheme I mean it's just crazy
and really you can go watch you can go
watch that coverage that we did on that
day because it actually when we went
through the website like we were reading
it live like as this nft [ __ ] was
happening um so go go follow Tony
Michael's podcast on YouTube go or a
channel and follow the Tony Michael's
podcast and Texas Paul will join us
tomorrow and I know we'll talk about
this Trading Card thing
but Gabe this is the same [ __ ] over and
over this John Edwards thing the CRT
they're always making [ __ ] up gas prices
I mean it just we're gonna get [ __ ]
committees that's what we're gonna call
them here on my show the Tony Michaels I
mean on Hunter Biden's laptop right and
I mean when you you bring up the cards
and gasoline is a good point these
people who complain about inflation and
gas prices we were so willing so willing
to drop 99 plus dollars to buy this
digital Trader card because it had it
had Trump's face on on some stock image
from the internet they stole it they
stole it yeah it's it is insane the the
depth that they went to make these
Trader cards but in that example you
know you got people like oh what about
groceries and gas prices and inflation
and they're like yeah but you should
also buy these 99
Trader gift cards for Donald Trump
and it's just like a great idea it
really shows you like their real
priority in their real
kind of motivation which is like
anything pro-republican or anything
Trump if you've pitched your kind of
card onto that bandwagon there then
you've got to continue and anything that
is you know pro-american in the sense of
making sure that Americans are taken
care of that we work to uh fight
inflation or gas prices or grocery
prices or housing prices or whatever it
might be anything like that Republicans
again and again and again you can
literally just look for the screenshots
of the vote count and show that it's a
overwhelming majority of Republicans who
vote in a on every one of those things
would actually help Americans and that
is what they do and they just distract
and go well what about what about Liz
Cheney losing by 40 points yeah and you
know dude what what Gabe's hitting on
here is perfect because you know old
dark Brandon just quiet competence just
getting it done what was the Consumer
Price Index increased last month you
know it was all about you know grocery
prices and gas prices and yeah point one
percent increase all right 0.1 percent
not one percent what way are the gas
prices
how what trajectory are their gas prices
at now are we gonna blame dark Brandon
at this yeah we're gonna blame him for
the listen the point is is that the
reason why Joe Biden is so effective is
because he doesn't listen to the noise
and really honestly the Trump chaos
machine is the noise that's the problem
we have and I want to show a perfect
example of diverting reality live in
front of a [ __ ] camera someone who is
the vice president of the United States
they Texas ball they went to the damn
Capital hang this guy because he
wouldn't do the deluge additional thing
that John Eastman and Donald Trump
wanted him to do and here he is on on
Fox News like oh well it's not Donald
Trump's fault it's the lawyer let's
listen again when it comes to the
Justice Department's decision about
about
um about bringing charges in the future
I would hope that they would not bring
charges against the former president I I
don't look I as I wrote in my book I
think the president's actions and words
on January 6 were Reckless
but I don't know that it's it's criminal
to take bad advice from lawyers
it is Criminal to take bad advice
criminal advice and to co-conspire with
an attorney to overthrow a government it
is illegal it's [ __ ] criminal it's
not rocket science and really honestly
this this placating to the Maga base as
if he's gonna win any kind of election
or primary anywhere with Donald Trump's
voters is [ __ ] full and then as you
can read in my book well you've got
every single time you see them on the
news or some interview they're like will
you vote for Donald Trump and they're
like well and you're like will you vote
like who if if he becomes enough like
well we'll have to see who the nominee
is okay let's assume that Donald Trump
is the nominee will you vote like well I
don't know but also in my book you know
like Bill Barr did the same thing when
he was on a PBS or whatever the a few
weeks ago it's the same type of thing
they keep pushing this idea of like we
will vote for Donald Trump if he's the
nominee but we won't tell you that right
now but in in the meantime buy my book
read up on what I have to say and try to
Rebrand myself as the the the person who
said no to Trump or whatever the
[ __ ] they want to spread and Mike
Pence is another example well I'll tell
you I I wouldn't vote for Donald Trump
if you paid me
um all the money that he made off or
laundered off the Trump trading cards
but I will say this our grift is to go
follow the Tony Michael's podcast on
YouTube so go do that um don't read Mike
Pence's book come follow our podcast on
YouTube just go over the channel and and
hit the Subscribe I do I do want to give
the committee I mean like the the Liz
Cheney and and uh Benny Thompson and the
whole committee has done a great job in
terms of laying out the facts and all of
the researchers in terms of being like
this is the person where they were when
they said it and obviously hand it off
to the doj and Jack Smith's team great
I do want to give them
uh you know and whether this was the TV
producer side of it you know or or what
what have you but I do believe obviously
this is right before they go for recess
for Holiday right they're not coming
back until the beginning of the year
when uh new people are getting sworn in
so I really do have to say like props to
them for at the very last moment
possible pretty much pushing out to say
hey remember us you saw us in October
but you're gonna see us again right now
and we're going to remind you with a
quick like things you saw last season on
the January 6th Insurrection is
all of these people what they said who
they said it about will put you we'll
sprinkle in some new stuff like with
hope Hicks and show you how even she
said uh not so sure we should do this
and she was like oh all about all about
the Legacy for Trump and also definitely
cooing he was definitely cool they
brought up uh Nick Luna and I don't know
if people know this but Nick Luna is
also connected to the nft Trump Trader
cards uh with the company that purchased
his likeness it's all connected it's a
big grip but I I like I said I do want
to give them big props for for putting
out this last minute like hey just in
case you forgot what's happening this
was it was at stake and this is what
we're defending and these are the people
that are trying to make sure that
actually democracy is saved
um you know post a midterm election and
especially because people are going to
go on holiday they're gonna go for
Christmas you're going to see their
manga relatives right exactly whatever
it might be they're going to interact
with other people and it's top of mind
so they're gonna bring it up and in the
idea that you brought up too is like
people are going to
questionably mistake this as convictions
which they're not good but the idea that
you can
throw that into the Kool-Aid and say oh
yeah he's convicted he got convicted and
they can try all they want with Jack
Smith John Edwards [ __ ] but you've
also got this other side of like all
right we're gonna [ __ ] throw in this
conviction [ __ ] too and we're gonna
remind everyone when everyone's together
eating over and throwing food at each
other because you're across from your
mag or relative remember Donald Trump is
[ __ ] and it might not be on one of
these others but it's going to be on the
Mar-A-Lago it's going to be on Fulton
County it's going to be on New York one
of these things are going to take it
down and it's his own [ __ ] fault if
he had shut the [ __ ] up let me bring
Elon Musk into this too same [ __ ]
deal man learn to shut the [ __ ] up if he
hadn't spent the last year being an
abject [ __ ]
the doj would actually likely be looking
at this as
man this is going to be really political
because it is it's going to be really
[ __ ] political because one political
party tried to overthrow our [ __ ]
government that cannot be prosecuted
without it being abjectly political
that's Politics as [ __ ] isn't it had
they shut the [ __ ] up if you hadn't had
Jim Jordan Andy Biggs Kevin McCarthy
even running their [ __ ] Mouse all
year long
this probably would have went away but
they have guaranteed they have made it
to where we have to prosecute them we
have to there is no way Jack Smith does
not come out with indictments there's no
way this country
functions if they don't come out with
indictments for this
Donald Trump's mouth has put him in
prison you know look at look at Peru
look at Germany they both had coup
attempts
in jail immediately
immediately this country has the most
lenient judicial system for a [ __ ]
wealthy old guys
in the world so they can scream all day
long oh we're victims we're picked on oh
[ __ ] you're not in [ __ ] jail
right now you should be in jail right
[ __ ] now you have been given every
opportunity to just shot
up and go away
couldn't do it no could not do it yeah
they won't do it they won't do it and we
talked about this before on the show and
I know we'll talk about it tomorrow but
we're at the top of the hour and I want
to thank the audience for putting up
with the with our little Snappy with
audio earlier
um I think if I can pull that front and
the pre-game coverage of the hearing I'm
gonna pull that video and see what the
audio is like Gabe Sanchez and if that
audio is good I'm gonna post it on our
YouTube channel see it Midas Touch wants
to post on their Channel too uh so go
follow at the Tony Michaels podcast on
YouTube it's the Tony Michaels podcast
go subscribe there if that video is
working and the audio is good on the on
the part that I can pull then I will
repost it so you can actually hear it
there was a lot of crackling I think our
connection was bad or something I could
hear fine we could hear finding the
broadcast but it wasn't connecting
through the stream properly so I
appreciate the audience sticking with
the hearing sticking with the coverage
sticking with the commentary and again
Gabe Texas Paul thanks for joining uh us
too today and waiting till the very end
uh always the funnest
um Trio that we have here uh The Three
Amigos as it were I guess maybe we
should be known as but tomorrow Texas
ball I want to talk more about the Trump
trading guards um on on Tuesdays with
Texas while on Taco Tuesday so everyone
tune in again go to the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube
um hit that subscribe button we'll we'll
do Tuesdays with Texas fall but if
you're on the Midas touch Network right
now if you're on their Channel hit the
Subscribe Button as well you're not
going to want to miss a single video I
know that Midas Touch is going to break
down every single part of this hearing
and all the media that will come with it
and what I mean by that is the response
or the non-response from the Republicans
because boy are we going to get plenty
plenty of response from these morons and
plenty of Gaslight fighting and lies and
[ __ ] rather it's John Edwards or or
Mike Pence saying well if attorneys give
you criminal advice and you follow it
you're not a criminal I guess so
whichever whichever
um whichever commentary it is everyone
thanks for joining us here on the Midas
touch Network again I want to thank all
the guests that we've had for these 10
hearings
um I could go down the list but I would
I would forget someone but everyone from
the legal ampers to Michael Cohen to
Jessica Denson the David Bender Dr
Rachel bidikoffer and everyone else in
between thank you thank you for joining
us and thank you for giving us your time
and making sure that you know this
information to take it out on Christmas
and deliver it up to your your Maga
Uncle Earl and make sure why we still
have the big audience can I throw a
Shameless plug in absolutely every
Sunday except for this Sunday because of
the holidays come see me on my YouTube
channel I do Sunday coffee with Texas
Paul every it's 11 o'clock Central so
you listen to me and go straight to the
game that's it so go go follow Texas
Paul just just type in Texas Paul on on
the YouTube's
um and they'll and he'll his channel
will pop up subscribe to him again
subscribe to the Midas touch Network
here you don't want to miss a single one
of those videos and do us a huge favor
go over to the Tony Michaels podcast
Channel and follow us there as well
fellas it's been a great run on these
select earrings and I'm glad you've been
here for every single one and we've
kicked ass took names
and I usually say on my show Surfs Up
[ __ ] so guess what we're at the
end Surf's Up [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]